la commission charbonneau aujourd'hui
deux témoins importants qui était
attendu l'ancien ministre libéral vous
le voyez marc yvan côté mais d'abord
l'ex organisateur du parti libéral
également pierre bibeau il a nié
monsieur bibelots avoir jamais participé
à du financement illégal au plq dit il
reportage sur cette portion ensuite on
retrouvera isabelle née catherine
d'abord
pierre bibeau a une longue feuille de
route au parti libéral mais depuis 2003
il est premier vice président corporatif
chez loto-québec et nie catégoriquement
avoir fait de la sollicitation pour le
parti il n'a jamais réclamé 30 mille
dollars à lino zambito non plus 26 vous
aura mis trois heures à cette rencontre
il m'apparaît mitrac mail dargier pas
demandé trente mille dollars et il m'a
pas rémi tremblay d'alors pierre bibeau
a son explication pour la visite des
ambito à son bureau en avril 2009 même
rencontré relativement alors un problème
de dézonage abois brière du possible
c'était pour une usine d'épuration d'eau
à boisbriand note je
pense aux sénateurs donc quand je pense
à un autre par paul me laisser passer
mais au lendemain du témoignage de lino
zambito à la commission il déclare qu'il
est allé vider ces deux coffrets de
sécurité à la banque et qu'il a annulé
sa marge de crédit pourquoi pourquoi
fermer deux coffrets de sûreté et
pourquoi
chaque match de crédit je comprends pas
moi non plus ces soldes comme vous et ce
avant de crever ta pomme dans mon état
normal pierre bibeau qui admet avoir eu
des pensées suicidaires a livré un
témoignage décousu
alors on y reviendra isabelle peut-être
sur pierre bibeau mais l'autre témoin
important aujourd'hui l'ex ministre
libéral marc yvan côté on a beaucoup
parlé de monsieur côté depuis le début
de cette commission de façon générale
isabelle il a reconnu que oui du
financement illégal
c'était chose courante au club oui
effectivement lui qui est passé
directement de la politique à la firme
de génie roche comme vice président au
développement des affaires on l'a
tellement dit il a concédé effectivement
que les grandes firmes donner à des
partis politiques c'était dans l'air du
temps bonne nécessairement pour se
garantir des contrats mais il disait si
on ne participait pas ses opérations
financières il y avait un risque qui le
port dit la nature du risque il n'a pas
non plus voulu reconnaître que c'était
en échange de contrats mais il savait
bien que ça huiler les relations avec
les donneurs d'ouvragé comme il le dit
mais il a tout de même reconnu que ce
système là où il a dit les machines
politiques sont devenus des monstres et
c'est un problème non pas d'un individu
mais c'est un problème de société et il
le considère la chose suivante donc vous
êtes d'accord avec moi que même si une
telle entreprise ou individu ce test est
dans les moeurs de contribuer le nyeleni
aujourd'hui de cesser
tenir aujourd'hui c'est nier une
évidence et je suis pas dedans la
commission pourrait d'hypocrite
et l'autre évidence isabelle c'est
qu'ils avaient de la valeur auprès de
roche et compagnes et donc du génie par
son passé politique par son réseau
partout au québec voilà et ça il le sait
est absolument il n'était pas ingénieur
ans il était il était professeur
d'histoire avant de se lancer en
politique
donc c'est certainement pas pour ses
capacités en génie que la firme a mis le
grappin sur lui comme il le dit jeanne
un réseau de contacts j'avais une
capacité à rencontrer des gens j'avais
une facilité à développer des projets
bref c'est sûr que ça aide une firme
d'avoir quelqu'un comme marc yvan côté
écouter l'a d'ailleurs expliqué cécile
germain
est ce que vous pensez avec les états de
service que j'avais aperçu que j'avais
besoin de contribuer financièrement pour
être capable d'avoir des informations
géologiques moi je pense que non
alors il dit qu'il pouvait avoir de
l'information notamment auprès de bruno
lortie qui était son chef de cabinet
longtemps qui a été celui de madame
normandeau mais pas de l'information
privilégiée at il dit ça se poursuit
demain on verra si on peut aller je veux
faire un jeu revenir en arrière une
seconde isabelle sur pierre bibeau donc
lui dit je n'ai pas accepté lé 30 mille
dollars dont on a beaucoup beaucoup
parlé du jem btu a même raconté qu'il
est allé le porter en personne à l'exo
québec donc là on a deux témoignages
contradictoires c'est tout on a des
témoignages contraction contradictoire
c'est tout mais il ya quand même des
éléments qui corroborent et il ya un
monsieur bibeau extrêmement nerveux 10
est empêtré dans ses danses et répondre
ceux relatifs mal dans ses explications
relativement ses nombreuses rencontres
avec l'inde lino zambito parce que c'est
pas la seule alors après ça on évalue il
faut voir il faut pas tirer les choses
au clair totalement c'est pas un procès
mais la commission peut tirer c'est
différent que la juge devra décider d'en
voilà merci de marie au revoir